spring has sprung and so have those
winds boy those winds have gusted well
over 60 miles an hour out at red rocks
66 mile an hour winds at midnight they
have really been howling harry reid
international 58 mile an hour winds
laughlin 50 plus north las vegas almost
up to 50. now it's all with a cold front
that moved through early yesterday
morning and so if you were outside you
probably noticed the direction of the
winds shifted from southwest to
northwest around that cold front
temps dropped about almost 10 degrees
between saturday and sunday we went from
near 80 for highs to about 70 yesterday
lots of low 50s some upper 40s 49 in
summerlin 47 centennial hills sunrise
mountain 37 out red rock really chilly
out there and we still have winds around
through the mountains the valley you've
got wind this morning various
neighborhoods in the las vegas valley
and especially along the colorado river
valley where wind advisories are still
posted and those have been extended
until 8 o'clock tonight 41 in kingman
your wind advisories go all the way
until tuesday because we expect those
winds to keep cranking more to the east
of southern nevada all right so the
system itself has just been moving over
to the four corners it's spinning snow
up into the rockies where we need it so
desperately to help eventually fill into
lake mead we're looking at another
system into the pacific northwest a lot
of wind over the southern plains and
they've got wildfires in texas so these
winds are not helping could see severe
weather over the deep south in the gulf
coast states today as that chilly system
spins its way east into the south so
yesterday so we were hoping we'd get
some rain from this system saturday
night into sunday morning which you see
we did get some showers but most of
those were focused on arizona now
mammoth mountain in california in the
sierra nevada they picked up four to
five inches of new snow and that helped
to kind of boost their spring skiing
there so they were very proud of that
and shared some video with us so they
said this will help uh you know
prolong their ski season and snowboard
season they've had over 200 inches about
216 inches of snow for the season there
at mammoth mountain so good for them boy
we sure could have used more snow for us
as well wind advisories as i say along
the colorado river valley today lakes
mead lake mojave those last until 8
o'clock tonight and for northwest
arizona they go all the way through
tuesday evening so we'll get back up to
74 today that's about 4 degrees warmer
than yesterday and then upper 70s
midweek
look how quickly we warm up with a ridge
of high pressure i know you're looking
at these numbers going what how do we go
from 74 to the 90s but we do in a hurry
87 thursday low 90s possible for friday
saturday and those would be new record
highs oh my goodness it won't last that
long